[music]
For a long time, the inhabitants of the southwestern historical
ancient Russian lands called themselves
Russian and Orthodox,
so
there are no problems for your rest
[music]
12 kilometers stand
And who are these shows, [ __ ] it’s not clear words to
Ukraine
Yeah, everything is understandable different hello Say
the word Polyana, then
you came to our Earth
Take the seeds, put them raw, even
sunflowers,
these are our comrades, close ones, among whom are
not only colleagues, friends, former
colleagues, but also relatives, people
connected with us by blood family.
now we have a place to live from you they
caught the Russians [ __ ] in the basement in our
yard with machine guns with all the military they
pull a pancake
you can drag back to Russia
Do you know where you are going
so destroy the nazi you met during
this time ancistrus to bander
Ukraine
for what you
came
to ukraine you think it's fun for me to
wait until 6 used to But if they
[ __ ] the [ __ ]
you are Belarus
I am Belarus strongly I only this is also
Ukraine who is Ukraine Damn I suggest you
lay down your weapons to [ __ ] before we
come you are not hit
That is, I live here I live
[music]
go in reverse
and let them go